when bringing the written word to the
movie theater it's sometimes in the
film's best interest to get rid of the
most disturbing stuff
everybody and their mother knows about
el james erotic romance novel 50 shades
of grey
naturally as one of the more memorable
best sellers of the decade james book
was destined for a major motion picture
adaptation
the movie hit theaters and was
unsurprisingly a huge box office success
despite predominantly unfavorable
reviews as fans of the book noticed
however one particular sequence from the
novel didn't make the cut
the infamous tampon scene in which
christian wants to get it on despite the
knowledge that it's anastasia's time of
the month
director sam taylor johnson told variety
it didn't make it into the movie it was
never even discussed
the film's producer michael deluca
agreed the book needed to put you in
anna's shoes to be a successful
experience
a lot of it was very literal the movie
didn't need to do that
it's a completely different medium the
romance film me before you known by many
for starring game of thrones mother of
dragons emilia clarke had the benefit of
being adapted for the big screen by the
novel's author herself
jojo moyes which only makes it more
interesting that the film lacks one
rather critical plot point
in the movie the female protagonist
louisa lou clark is quirky and
intelligent
which is why nobody really understands
what keeps her from spreading her wings
in the book however we know exactly what
lou's deal is while drinking with a
group of guys in high school she was
sexually assaulted
something she keeps firmly under wraps
this critical plot point is used to
explain pretty much everything about lou
from her weird and overtly non-sexual
sense of style to her offbeat
personality moise claims they tried for
six months to put that scene into the
movie
but it simply didn't fit emma donahue
didn't just write the impactful 2010
novel room
she also wrote the screenplay for the
award-winning novel's film adaptation
which itself was nominated for multiple
academy awards including best picture
as is often the case however donahue
struggled with the harsh reality that
not every scene from the book is good
for the movie
in the case of room donohue chose to cut
out the scene in which
ma tells her son jack that she gave
birth to a baby girl before him
because she had no medical attention in
captivity the child was tragically
stillborn despite having written the
scene into the script
donahue made the tough move to remove it
completely donahue told variety
the stillbirth story slammed the brakes
and yanked us back toward the tragic
past
i have to grudgingly admit that the
film's better without it
the entire conceit of the hunger games
is built on death pain torture
and cruelty in a fascist nation called
pan m an annual contest selects two
children from each of 12 districts to
fight to the death both to amuse the
elitist in charge
and to punish the population for a
failed uprising from many years earlier
i volunteer as tribute not only does
president snow's government in the
capital enable the deaths of 23 children
each year in elaborate war games but it
develops and utilizes technology to lead
to more suffering
both in and out of the hunger games
while suzanne collins very successful
hunger games books were aimed at teens
and children the movie adaptations
eliminated some of the capital's
particularly ghastly acts
for example anyone who tries to escape
pan am and gets caught as well as those
mixed up in potential
uprisings are turned into what are
called a voxes their tongues are cut out
meaning they can't talk and they're
forced into a life of slavery in the
capital capital employed hunger games
makers also utilize so-called mutations
genetically modified creatures to make
the competition even deadlier the final
three competitors in the first hunger
games novel face off with wolf type
monsters
and thanks to science each of these
so-called mutts unsettlingly bears the
face of one of the children sacrificed
earlier in the games
many of filmmaker cameron crowe's works
are based on true stories
in 1981 crow published vast times at
ridgemont high a true story and to
observe teenagers in their element the
22 year old writer pretended to be a
senior in a real california high school
that book became the basis of the 1982
classic teen movie
fast times at ridgemont high one of the
most salacious and eye-opening accounts
of teen life
ever put to film the breakout star was
future ultra serious two-time academy
award-winning actor sean penn who
starred as jeff spicoli a well-liked
good-natured surfer stoner dimwit
all in here some tasty waves cool buzz
and i'm fine
but in the books piccoli is a target of
his classmate's derision both for his
lack of intelligence and
outright cruelty her crow's account a
student's father and sister are killed
in a grisly car accident and spicoli
burst into the kid's class showing off a
newspaper article with crash photos the
kid cried
and nobody spoke to spicoli for a month
that scene didn't make it into the
mostly comedic fast times film
michael crichton's 1990 novel jurassic
park is a techno thriller detailing the
death
and destruction that occurs when the
science created dinosaur clones that
inhabit a remote theme park start
attacking as many humans as they can
one of the scariest and most memorable
scenes in the blockbuster 1993 film
adaptation is when small but deadly
velociraptors track down
kids lex and tim as they hide in a
kitchen they get out safely but a far
worse and sickening fate befalls a much
younger child in creighton's novel the
first sequences of the book in which
costa rica is plagued by a series of
mysterious lizard attacks didn't make it
into the movie those lizards are
obviously jurassic park escapees
and in one scene from the novel a nurse
discovers three little dinosaurs
attacking a baby
the 1990 film misery is an adaptation of
a stephen king novel
and it's a horror story that doesn't
involve monsters ghosts or creatures the
scary thing in misery is a human
and it's annie wilkes played by kathy
bates annie is a super fan of romance
novelist paul sheldon
played by james khan and she gets the
chance to meet him after saving him from
a car accident but when she finds out
that paul's upcoming novel will kill off
her favorite character annie's adoration
turns sinister and she holds paul
hostage in her home
forcing him to write what she wants when
annie leaves for the day
paul goes snooping in the house to learn
more about his captor upon her return
she realizes what he did and restrains
him against a bed
i know you've been out
then to ensure he doesn't try another
escape she violently and graphically
shatters his ankles with a sledgehammer
perhaps director rob reiner and
screenwriter william goldman are just
more squeamish than king
in the original book annie doesn't club
paul's ankles she amputates a foot with
an
axe and then cauterizes the bloody stump
wound with a blow torch
jiminy cricket from the 1940 film
pinocchio is one of the most memorable
characters in the vast universe of
disney animated films
and for good reason he's kind patient
and serves as the conscience of
marionette turned real boy pinocchio
writers and animators greatly
embellished and fleshed out the
character for the film based on carlo
calot's episodic fairy tale novel the
adventures of pinocchio published in
serial form in
1881 and 1882. in the source text jiminy
cricket is known only as talking cricket
and he isn't a major character early in
the story when pinocchio is left home
the talking cricket advises the boy to
head back to the safety and comfort of
home pinocchio flies into a rage over
being told what to do
and he picks up a hammer and throws it
at the talking cricket pinocchio harbors
no remorse over this incident which
would have made for a very dark disney
film telling geppetto quote it was his
own fault for i didn't want to kill him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you